[Musique]
c'est le refuge d'une des grandes
histoires d'amour du 20e siècle la
maison elsa triolet aragon c'est un
havre de tranquillité mais aussi
d'écriture pour les deux auteurs éponyme
elsa triolet et louis aragon c'est ce
lieu si tu as enfin ronny ville que nous
venons vous faire découvrir pour ce
nouveau cette fille culture c'est parti
au programme cette semaine au lieu de
mémoire et de création artistique la
maison elsa triolet aragon abrite des
expositions temporaires à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines des spectacles
on lui aussi toute l'année nous
reviendrons avec son directeur sur ce
lieu si symbolique pour les deux
écrivains du xxème siècle des pièces de
théâtre sur le thème de la transmission
voici le programme du premier festival
des vadrouilles théâtrale à plaisir du
12 au 15 mai le théâtre coluche la clé
des champs et le conservatoire de la
commune se sont associés pour proposer
une programmation éclectique du 12 au 22
mai versailles jazz festival revient à
versailles but qu es jouy en josas des
artistes phares du répertoire jazz se
succèderont blanc de concert le bassiste
kyle eastwood sera l'invité d'honneur de
cette 16e édition
[Musique]
pour entrer dans le vif du sujet et
présenter ce lieu je suis avec guillaume
roubaud kwasi bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le directeur de la maison elsa triolet
aragon cette maison tout d'abord c'est
une acquisition des deux écrivains en
1951 c'est ça exactement sont deux
écrivains qui ont vécu plutôt dans des
conditions un peu difficiles parfois
certains moments de leur vie mais qui au
lendemain de la guerre est bien sont
évidemment non seulement sorti de la
clandestinité puisqu'ils sont tous les
deux résisté mais ont une notoriété une
autorité dans le monde littéraire très
importante elle à triolet la première
femme à avoir reçu le prix goncourt et
aragon est devenu le poète national à
certains égards et donc il a fait cette
maison pour pouvoir être au calme et
pour pouvoir écrire un peu loin du
tumulte de la vie parisienne ils y sont
restés jusqu'à leur mort exactement
c'est à dire que ils arrivent ici en
1951 alors il continue d'avoir un
appartement qu'il loue à paris mais ils
sont quasiment tout le temps ici à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines qu'est la
maison des amis aussi où ils reçoivent
beaucoup d'artistes de cinéastes de
poètes de peintres et en 1970 c'est les
à triolet qui a réellement n'avez tout
parquet ramener toute la maison
n'oubliez pas qu'elle a un diplôme
d'architecturé et architecte de
formation au départ eh bien elle décide
d'être enterré ici et grâce à
l'autorisation que georges pompidou en
1970 bien tous les deux sont enterrés là
dans le parc de la de la maison elle
d'abord et puis lui quand il décède en
1982 et comment ensuite ce lieu est
devenu ce qu'il est aujourd'hui un lieu
symbolique un sanctuaire mais en fait en
1976 aragon des sites de
donner ses manuscrits à la nation
française
donc effet au cnrs de donner également
et bien la maison à à la nation
française c'est sa formule et c'est ce
qui va devenir une réalité à sa mort un
peu après 1982 grâce à jean ristat cinq
héritiers et à l'état qui acceptent le
legs est une association à ce moment là
est fondée
qui va donc s'occuper de ceux de ce lieu
pour en faire un lieu de patrimoine de
mémoire mais aussi un lieu vivant autour
des activités de la vie culturelle
divisé en plus en plusieurs espaces il
ya la maison il ya un moulin le mode
hard dancing exactement c'est à dire que
au départ ici vous avez ce grand parc
qui permet évidemment de recevoir de
faire beaucoup d'activités vous avez la
maison telle qu'elle a été habité par le
couple et là rien n'a bougé il n'y a pas
de muséographie de scénographie on a
laissé vraiment la maison telle qu'elle
est et ce qui fait aussi tous sont
toutes sans ce caractère touchant
émouvant et puis il ya des espaces qui
ont été réaménagés qui n'étaient pas
habitées par le couple directement qui
sont des lieux d'exposition et puis on a
fait l'acquisition en fin d'un bal parc
est que tard lieu assez magique et qui
nous permet de recevoir comme ça des
concerts des spectacles des conférences
et comme vous l'avez dit aujourd'hui la
maison est un lieu d'exposition un lieu
de culture avec plusieurs événements qui
s'y passe par exemple depuis le 5
février l'exposition autographe de
l'artiste christian gainey alias c215 a
investi les murs ici des portraits de
grandes figures avec leurs écrits est-ce
que vous arriverez à tous les
reconnaître vous propose de découvrir ce
reportage
[Musique]
c'est au coeur de la maison triolet
aragon à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines que
les amoureux d'art et de littérature ont
rendez-vous autographes une exposition
qui regroupe street art fresque éphémère
et poésie tout ça réalisé par l'artiste
c215 alias christian guémy d'abord vous
dire qu'on est très heureux d'accueillir
cette exposition 7,215 parce que 215 et
à un grand artiste qu à une action
internationale mais qui est très lié au
monde de la poésie la littérature voit
dans une maison d'écrivain on nous avait
beaucoup de chance dans les rues de
paris rome londres são paulo c215 a
réalisé de nombreux portraits de figures
littéraires à travers le monde entier
les visiteurs découvrent ainsi les
traits de paul verlaine arthur rimbaud
ou encore victor hugo
[Musique]
là on a donc des photographies de grands
poètes qui ont deux romancières parfois
je vois ici qui ont été réalisés dans la
rue là par exemple vous avez aimé
césaire qu'on retrouve là on peut voir
aussi des textes de célèbres écrivains
c'est ce dialogue entre images et mots
que l'artiste a voulu retranscrire
qu'est ce qu'on voit ici eh bien on voit
une série de textes c'est très émouvant
de les voir ici j'en ai textes de grands
poètes qui ont été écrits par eux-mêmes
dans des textes autographes donc là par
exemple on a un texte un grand ami
d'aragon qui est venu ici plusieurs fois
qu'est donc pas les lois par exemple ici
écrit à la main et en regard de ces
textes vous avez le portrait que
proposent ces 215 de chacun de ces
grands poètes qui forment son panthéon
un peu personnel dans cette exposition
c215 propose une large palette de ses
capacités artistiques
après ces oeuvres réalisées dans la rue
les visiteurs peuvent découvrir une
sculpture de louis aragon en deux
dimensions ou contempler un portrait de
sa mère réalisé sur un vitrail le clou
de l'exposition cette immense fresque
éphémère des deux écrivains elsa triolet
et louis aragon conçu spécialement pour
l'occasion exactement une oeuvre
éphémère qui a été réalisé pour cette
exposition on est très heureux donc on
retrouve une - ragondins côté elsa
triolet de l'autre
cette oeuvre sera visible jusqu'au 8 mai
date de la fin de l'exposition c'est
aussi l'occasion de visiter ou de
revisiter la maison des deux écrivains
elsa triolet et louis aragon dans ce
magnifique écrin de verdure est
d'ailleurs attention il reste très peu
de temps pour voir l'exposition qui
s'achève le 8 mai prochain qu'est ce qui
se prépare ensuite d'autres expositions
d'autres événements alors d'une manière
générale 2022 est une année très riche
pour nous parce que c'est le 40e
anniversaire de la mort d'aragon en
décembre et donc toute l'année on a des
initiatives autour d'aragon et puis au
mois de mai on a plusieurs événements
importants la nouvelle exposition partie
du 14 mai qui va nous amener du côté des
mondes optique et de la lumière avec
miguel chevalier d'exposition importante
donc vernissage le samedi 14 mai et le
samedi 21 mai c'est la nuit des musées
l'occasion de découvrir la maison sous
un jour si je puis dire assez différents
et puis d'assister à un grand concert
qui sera donné par deux grands artistes
qui sont raquel camarina johan héros qui
nous amèneront du côté de la musique
classique ce sera un moment je crois
assez magique et bien voilà les rendez
vous sont pris merci guillaume ribes
reproché d'avoir été avec nous merci
rond
[Musique]
sortez vos plus beaux masques et vos
plus belles tirades à présent car on
part du côté de plaisir qui organise son
premier festival de théâtre ça s'appelle
les vadrouille théâtrale tout terrain
voici une petite présentation de
l'événement
[Musique]
les vadrouille théâtrale tout terrain
nouveau vocable ici à la ville de
plaisir petite innovation un événement
assez ludique assez familial qui a pour
but un petit peu à l'instar de ce qui se
passe le festival d'avignon de montrer
les différentes facettes de l'art
dramatique dans les différents lieux de
la ville est également en extérieur
l'idée c'était bien sûr de faire
découvrir les établissements culturels
de la ville au public qui n'auraient pas
encore eu l'occasion d'y aller donc bien
sûr le théâtre coluche la clé des chants
d'une petite scène à côté mais ici aussi
dans le parc du château donc la cour des
communs qui pourra accueillir une
représentation en extérieur et puis le
théâtre robert manuel
[Musique]
c'est vadrouille théâtrale tout terrain
propose six événements au cours du long
week-end du jeudi vendredi samedi
dimanche j'en profite donc pour
illustrer peut-être le premier le jeudi
soir qui est original dans la mesure où
c'est une triste qui a été en immersion
dans le quartier du val ibo et qui a
rencontré les habitants pour formuler
finalement un texte une pièce de théâtre
[Musique]
quelques représentations sont gratuites
et d'autres sont à des tarifs très
raisonnables de 7 à 15 euros on est
vraiment dans le spectacle abordable
pour tous
n'hésitez pas à venir surtout que le
dimanche donc ça se passera ici dans la
cour des communs du château et au
théâtre robert manuel laisser la journée
dédiée au grand pique nique en plein air
familiale ici dans le parc du château
[Musique]
cette année en fait les retrouvailles de
nombreux événements culturels à
l'exemple du versailles jazz festival
après deux ans d'annulation faute de co
vide il est de retour des 12 au 22 mai
prochain au programme dix concerts
répartis entre versailles bucs et jouy
en josas l'une des têtes d'affiché de ce
grand retour nous vient tout droit des
états unis il a composé la musique de
nombreux films million dollar baby gran
torino invictus c'est bien sûr qu'elle
eastwood il se représentera au palais
des congrès de versailles le 21 mai
prochain olivier si le président du
festival nous parle du rendez vous à
venir avec wilfrid richie et patrick
jacques de dixmude
c'est évidemment le rendez vous phare de
notre festival 2022 bien évidemment
avoir une vedette de la dimension de
kyle eastwood et pour nous à la fois un
honneur et c'est une grande chance le
flou typo pour nous d'avoir un
contrebassiste de cette de cette
pointure et puis de pouvoir bénéficier
de cette merveilleuse salle du palais
des congrès pour l'accueillir dans un
écrin digne de lui je dure et ce ne sera
pas le seul à se produire dans le cadre
du festival on pourra aussi découvrir
sur scène de new york blue note qing
tête à université ouverte versailles ça
ce sera le 20 mai oui tout est fait
alors je suis très heureux ça c'est une
autre tête d'affiche pour nous nous
avons la chance de pouvoir faire venir
trois grands solistes de la scène jazz
new yorkaise donc on à dmitry baevsky le
saxophoniste en a le pianiste jay payton
et le trompettiste jo manière et lee
nous avons toujours essayé depuis le
début du festival et nous y sommes jusqu
alors parvenu à proposer un niveau de
standards techniques et artistiques
de nature à satisfaire les amateurs les
plus exigeants donc assez de le message
plutôt vers l'est et les grands amateurs
de jazz il ne risque pas d'être déçu en
venant à nos concerts et à tous les
autres je dirai ce que je vous disais un
petit peu un petit peu avancé qu en fait
vu la diversité des formes de jazz que
nous proposons pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas le jazz ils peuvent
trouver la porte d'entrée je dirais
qu'ils qui leur convient le mieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on termine cette édition par un
concert ou plutôt un duo entre
violoncelle et piano à strict cyrano
cyan et nathanaël gouin se
représenteront le vendredi 13 mai au
théâtre alexandre dumas de
saint-germain-en-laye du schumann du
brahms ou encore des compositions
personnelles d'astrid si la notion
surnommée la petite étoile du
violoncelle ce concert c'est la promesse
d'un moment suspendu dans lutte
et en parlant de moment suspendu dans le
temps moi je vais me poser quelques
minutes ici c'est la fin de ce set 8
culture rendez vous dès la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle édition
présentée par célia 400 go à bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]